na gut das sieht wirklich nicht so lang
raus und das signal nicht lecker aus was
sind jetzt redet was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video leute ich hoffe natürlich euch
geht's gut gab es euch selbst in den
kommentaren gewünscht ich muss den
anfang gerade noch mal neu aufnehmen
weil legen wir heute morgen hat das
nicht aufgenommen auf jeden fall geht es
heute um den am schlechtesten bewerteten
nicht kann es immer noch nicht es geht
um den am schlechtesten bewerteten
mcdonald's glaube ich dass wir jetzt so
halbwegs richtig wir schauen uns jetzt
erstmal die bewertung an
ich meine es gibt ja viele punkte auf
die man achten kann oder achten sollte
mit service menü sauberkeit toiletten
keine ahnung alles mögliche was halt so
gibt und darum geht es heute
wir schauen wie schnell die bewertung an
was sie noch gut sagen muss es geht
heute nicht um buchrezensionen weil das
ding ist so mcdonald's filialen burger
king filialen die kann man alle
irgendwie bei google nicht bewerten
zumindest habe ich da nichts gefunden
deswegen sind wir über eine externe
seite heute bei die heißt jetzt kennt er
ja wahrscheinlich und da ist der
herausgestochen mit irgendwie wartet man
zwölf bewertungen und diese zwölf
bewertungen sind alle ein stern also das
ding hat wirklich eine tolle einstellung
bewertung schlechter geht's nicht ist ja
schon heftig so und die schauen wir uns
mal kurz an und ein paar bewährt und
sind auch schon etwas älter die hier ist
jetzt sogar von 2014 an und für sich ein
moderner mcdonald's mit mcdonald's café
allerdings keine siebträger
kaffeemaschine wie üblich bei mehr als
zehn kunden völlig überfordert der eine
stern ist einer zuviel betrachtet man
die ekelhaft verdreckten toiletten gut
das sieht wirklich nicht so dass ich gar
nicht länger aus was sind das keine
siebträger kaffeemaschine verstehe ich
nicht die sich immer so etwas aufregen
ist dann halt mal leider so aber gut
cola zero und süß so sind aus das
personal ist überfordert und
unfreundlich einsturz der bestellungen
ist erst nach langer diskussion möglich
den laden kann man sich sparen die sind
auch noch lustig freunde der
angestellten werden vorgezogen wobei nur
zwei kassen auf waren und die kunden 20
das unterirdische tempo raus müssen
sorry aber geht garnicht personal
unfreundlich extrem lange wartezeiten
waren es einmal da
dieses mal gab es ein mccafé noch nicht
mal sagen ein absolutes no go also diese
ein sterne bewertungen sind auch
wirklich harten ich meine nur weil es
keinen kaffee gibt oder keine sahne
gibt's direkt ein stern wegen den
unfreundlichen mitarbeiter haben schauen
wir mal und wir sagen wir lieber gar
nicht lange checken laden mal ab ich bin
gespannt wie immer und ich wünsche euch
viel spaß beim zuschauen das ist auf
jeden fall noch nach oben dafür weitere
parks und trap in die kommentare was ich
noch testen soll weiß ich noch ganz gut
sagen wo ich die checks sehr sehr gerne
meinen instagram account ab 30 einfach
alex wie weil ich habe das extrem
krasses vor
das passt sich dann auf dem münsterberg
denn die story also was ich dann machen
werde es ist wirklich so next level
würde ich mal sagen deswegen wenn ihr
das nicht verpassen wollen würde mich
sehr freuen wenn hinten ab check und wir
verletzt los wie gesagt jetzt glaubt so
leute dann machen wir es mal auf dem weg
alter meine nase hoch ich selbst lustig
aus weiteres scheiße also das war super
hat von euch wenn ihr jetzt sich die
ganze zeit was meine nase achtet oder
das rote rät hier wir können uns auf
jeden fall los danach fahre ich direkt
zur uni weil das passt ganz gut und das
gleich als mittagszeit und ich bin
wirklich mal sehr gespannt wie es wird
weil ich bin bis jetzt auch noch nie
gezielt zu einem schlechten macdonald
gefallen
ich kann mich auch kaum erinnern an
irgendeinen der mann schlecht war oder
so zumal ja eh ziemlich geringe
ansprüche hat aber ich kann mir schon
vorstellen dass es auf jeden fall
schlecht geht wenn die mitarbeiter nicht
gut miteinander kommunizieren wenn die
überhaupt keinen bock auf ihren job
haben und so weiter
deswegen senken wir das jetzt mal ab und
schauen ob es wirklich so ist wie in den
rezensionen geschrieben
und ja ich würde sagen wir sind uns
gleich wenn wir da sind wir jetzt
erstmal los letzte heute da hinten ist
schon der mcdonald's ich bin dort schon
einmal dran vorbeigefahren ich weiß wie
das aussehen könnte wenn sie schon keine
ahnung sagt wirklich sehr modern aus ich
glaube es ist auch einer von diesen
neueren und ja ich bin mal gespannt was
mich erwartet also ich war wirklich sehr
überrascht wenn es plötzlich so schlecht
ist wie es im internet steht
wir werden sehen
also da ist das ding wie gesagt sieht
extrem modern aus finde ich
[Musik]
hallo ich hätte gern einen schießplatz
nur mittlere rohleistung kann einmal die
hurley preis und vier so käser gefüllt
ok dann egal und dazu noch ein salat
auch wenn nach so leicht zugenommen
zum ersten
so leute eigentlich habe ich noch
deutlich mehr bestellt das gab es nur
alles nicht ja leute bestellen jetzt
noch einen ziemlich schwierigen café sag
ich mal so schwer zu machen und mal
gucken ob das was wird und dann geht es
wieder nach hause weil auch gegessen
habe ich weiß auch nicht viel
wir sehen uns gleich
durch händewaschen vergleicht man das
wir sind die toiletten
[Musik]
über
[Applaus]
mit
dankeschön
leute ich wollte eigentlich auf meine
kamera wieder wechseln die ist leider
leer ich habe die voll vergessen
aufzuladen
auf jeden fall muss ich jetzt erst
stelle in die uni und dann mache ich
weder noch ein gesamt fazit ihr habt
allerdings wahrscheinlich schon gemerkt
das ja ist ja ein ziemlich großes
problem gehabt natürlich darf man nicht
vergessen das ist ein mcdonald's aber
ich finde ich stelle mich da auch nicht
an wenn ich sage dass der service besser
sein könnte sagen wir es mal so und da
gehen wir später noch ein bisschen
genauer darauf ein also wir sehen uns
später wieder so leute was geht
mittlerweile wieder zu hause
das ist immer noch rot wie heute morgen
war rudolf in den kommentaren möchte ich
mindestens 500 mal lesen hashtag leute
eben muss sicher aufwand so film der
akku war leer
um den kaffee habe ich mal noch
mitgenommen ein bisschen was ist noch
drin also das meistens natürlich nicht
mehr
das war ja so eine karamell edition für
sportliche drei euro 49 ja sie sieht aus
wie ein ganz normaler kaffee
ihr habt das nur wahrscheinlich auch auf
dem video gesehen
ich habe so gesagt ein karamell kaffee
und die war so direkt so auf was habe
ich noch nie gemacht haben zumindest
extrem so rüber und generell zu dem
laden ich habe sie am anfang gesagt dass
ich nicht so ganz typisch irgendwas
bestelle sondern halt schon ein bisschen
die verkäufer herausfordern will sagt
was man so also ist jetzt vielleicht
auch ein bisschen übertrieben gesagt
aber was halt finde ich wirklich nicht
geht ist wenn man sich so die produkte
anschauen und die es dort gibt im
internet und dies dann aber zum großteil
halt irgendwie nicht gibt also ich habe
mir was habe ich diese käse gipfel
bestellt mit denen ja auch noch darüber
geworben wurde also die kinder überall
gab es nicht dann habe ich diese curly
freis bestellt ich weiß ja wie die kennt
sind eigentlich ganz lecker kann auch
gut sein dass die nicht mehr im
sortiment sind also ich finde sie jetzt
gerade nicht auf der homepage allerdings
hängen die dann noch überall wenn man
draußen vorbei gegangen ist und die gab
es nicht dann habe ich noch ein salat
bestellt weil man sich ja so denkt so
also ich würde niemals auf die idee
kommen wir bei märkten salat zu
bestellen aber ich dachte einfach kommen
wir bestellen ist aber mal noch ein
salat weil ich hatte bis dahin nur zwei
oder drei sachen und den salat gab es
auch nicht und wie gesagt das ist immer
noch macdonald man sollte da jetzt nicht
die höchsten ansprüche an habe ich auch
nicht aber da muss ich
dass ich schon in vielen filialen mal
war auch wenn ich nicht mehr oft dahin
gehen wo es halt nicht so war also das
finde ich immer wichtig dass es die
produkte gibt bei der sache ist halt der
service natürlich ist ja kein geheimnis
und man merkt es zu arbeiten muss man
jetzt nicht mehr jahren eine ausbildung
machen sondern einfach so dass man sagt
okay ich brauche jetzt den job dann geht
man dahin und ich glaube dann ist das
auch relativ easy möglich ist ja auch
überhaupt nichts verwerfliches ich meine
es ist gut dass es solche jobs gibt
trotzdem finde ich ist dann wichtig dass
man zb leute die sich damit kaffee
machen verschiedene kaffee arten wie man
es auch immer nennen will dass man da
halt vielleicht so ein bisschen geschult
wird oder halt auch nur leute einsetzt
ist wirklich können es völlig egal was
das jetzt für ein restaurant ist eine
wichtige sache so er hat sich alles
gesehen auf dem video und könnt euch
sicherlich gut eine eigene meinung
bilden größeren ganzen was halt ein ganz
typischer mcdonald's der jetzt nicht so
den besten service hatte meiner meinung
nach und wo vor allem viele sachen gar
nicht im sortiment vor allem aber es hat
geschmeckt wie immer so und ich will
mich da jetzt auch gar nicht weiter
beschwerden sind dann halt immer diese
kleinigkeiten wodurch da dieser extrem
schlechten bewertung zustande kommt das
wars mit dem video das mir sehr gerne
doch noch um da abonniert mich auf jeden
fall bei instagram dass wir da auf jeden
fall krass und wir sehen uns morgen oder
übermorgen wieder gibt's neues video
haut rein und abonnieren